given all that talk of parties and the
party leadership in crisis we'll be
joined by conservative party chair
oliver dowden
labour's leadership has been biding its
time but has now called for boris
johnson to resign
i'll speak to shadow health secretary
wes streeting
a man who knows plenty about leading the
conservative party when it's well behind
in the polls is former leader ian duncan
smith
he's also deeply concerned about the
urgent warning from mi5 this week of a
chinese agent influencing mps
well you'll have heard the name sue grey
again and again and again this week
she's the senior civil servant holding
an investigation into parties held in
downing street
so much for faceless bureaucrats i'll
speak to the general secretary of the
white hall union the fda dave penman
and with the imminent threat of another
russian invasion of ukraine and rising
global tensions i spoken to kurt volcker
he was u.s ambassador to nato and u.s
special representatives for ukraine
having served under presidents bush
obama
and trump
but first
i'm joined by the chair of the
conservative party oliver dunn and good
morning mr dowden good morning um
can we just start with the issue that i
think will still concern most people in
this country
is omicron in retreat
well we've seen some very promising data
whether that's in relation to infections
or hospitalizations and that of course
hasn't happened by accident it's
happened because so many people have
taken that booster vaccine and thanks
the drive we gave it before christmas
we've now got over 60 of the total
population covered with the booster
vaccine and actually over 90 of over 50.
so that gives us
pause for hope and optimism that we may
be emerging from the worst of omicron so
it is it is good news but it's thanks to
all that hard work that has happened
should we then expect the lifting of the
restrictions when the review comes in 10
days time well it's always been my hope
that we would have the plan b
restrictions for the shortest period
possible i'm under no doubt the kind of
burdens this puts hospitality wider
business schools and so on under and i
want us to to get rid of those if we
possibly can the signs are encouraging
but clearly they will wait to see the
data ahead of that final decision but
the likelihood is that that is what will
happen those restrictions will be lifted
unless we see something surprising in
the data well it all seems to be heading
in the right direction particularly
crucially in relation to
hospitalizations which seem to be
plateauing you've seen those very good
headline numbers it's heading in the
right direction now i'm very hopeful and
optimistic but clearly we'll await the
data at the point of the decision before
making that final decision let me ask
you about another big uh challenge
facing government mr putin
uh
has essentially brewed
uh a rather dangerous situation on the
border with ukraine he's got a hundred
thousand troops there waiting for his
orders um the negotiations in vienna
this week basically drew a blank um
what's government doing to avoid war
well
it is important that we have that kind
of engagement that we saw in vienna and
we were represented by minister cleverly
at that we continue to work with the
united states and with our allies and we
need to continue to be robust as we have
been in saying to russia that if it
infringes on the sovereignty
of the ukraine it will face severe
consequences we need to be united in
sending that message and we are what do
severe consequences
look like i mean
what does that mean well we have said
there'll be severe economic consequences
sanctions regimes and so on but that tap
and russia needs to be in no doubt at
all that we would not allow this to
happen without those those consequences
clearly the defense secretary has said
this is a different matter given that
ukraine isn't a member of nato when it
comes to direct western military
intervention but nonetheless we will be
very robust in our our action i know
that president biden is very much
committed to that and of course he has
been in touch with prime minister boris
johnson about that
look i've asked you about two major
challenges facing the government i could
equally have asked about the cost of
living and the energy prices or brexit
and northern ireland or the ballooning
fiscal deficit or about the chinese
communist party's influence infiltration
of parliament yet all of that is being
dwarfed
this morning uh and day after day by the
series of revelations about conduct in
number 10 downing street and by the way
the conduct of prime minister and mrs
johnson
when do you plan to tell boris johnson
that if the conservative party is to
lead us through these challenges
he can no longer be prime minister you
can't afford him anymore
well i don't agree with that analysis i
think boris johnson should of course
remain as our prime minister and i'll
tell you why it's precisely for the
conversation we're just having now it
was the prime minister that made that
call about having the mass booster
programme which is ensured we're getting
through the worst form of crime at the
same time he made the call despite the
huge pressure and you may have
remembered this i recall it around
having a further lockdown in the face of
that omicron variant he made the right
call and has meant that we've managed to
have the most open economy in europe and
the most vast economy in europe the two
are linked together and i think when it
comes to those big calls he's made the
right call now of course i don't
diminish for a second that the kind of
events that we've seen were totally
wrong i was angered by them my
constituents were angered by them the
whole country was angered by them and
it's absolutely right the prime minister
said we'll get to the bottom of them and
i'll tell you that when he responds to
the house of commons this is committed
to doing so he will make sure that we
address the kind of culture that has
allowed that to happen in the first
place it's going to have to be a pretty
dramatic response i mean
at the very least
your job is to get the conservative
party back into government
you've turned an 80-seat majority two
years ago
into what is now a consistent 10
deficit in the polls and that is down to
mr johnson
he is the obstacle
to your doing your job
well
we all know that opinion polls vary what
matters to me what matters very much
what matters to the british system what
matters to the british people
is first of all they rightly expect us
to get a grip of this situation it was
totally wrong the the events that
happened it's absolutely right the
premises apologize and he will need to
take further steps and he will take
those further steps when he makes a
statement to the house of commons but it
is also the case that we need to address
not just covert and thank goodness we're
making progress as we come out of
omicron but also on the consequences of
covid whether that's clearing the nhs
backlog or whether that's rebuilding the
economy we need that kind of leadership
to get us through it and that's what
people expect of course we take these
things seriously and we must address
them but we must also address the
consequences
what could he possibly say about what we
already know has taken place
that would change opinions about that
culture you yourself mentioned
downing street
and in whitehall i mean what could he
possibly say well of course it's
important that we first get to the facts
of everything that happened now the
prime minister has already apologized in
respect of one event that that happened
we need to get all the facts that's what
sue gray's doing through her report we
need to look at how that stacks up
against the rules at the time and the
prime minister needs to respond to that
now you won't expect me to get into the
detail of that response but i can tell
you from the many conversations i've had
with the prime minister and what you saw
from him in the house on wednesday is
that he is committed to upping our game
we must improve the culture we must do
better i hear people's anger i know it
and we've got to respond to that yeah
but you know he himself said at pmq's
there was a party i was there i mean we
don't need two greater tanners so tim
one of your own mps uh tim london this
morning has made that point we don't
need to know
what sue gray might or might not have
found in the in the dusty files or from
some junior employees he's told us
himself
well i think it's important to
understand what the the sue grey inquiry
is doing it's not just in relation to
the event that happened i believe on the
20th of may it first of all looks at the
range of events where there's been
speculation about what may have happened
but in addition to that crucially it
also
allows people to come forward and bring
forward any further allegations so they
can properly be examined once we've got
a full picture of the facts
independently that will then allow the
prime minister to respond to it now of
course that is going to require a change
of culture and i know that the prime
minister is committed to leading that
and i know that the prime minister
feels a sincere sense of regret and has
apologized profoundly for what happened
and that is genuine but i think people
need to hear that in response in the
statement that he will make in response
to the sugree report
look you know we can
bandy
words about what sue grey may or may not
produce she can't do anything about it
actually because all you can do is say
what the facts are in the end in the
slightly bizarre situation it's the
prime minister himself who will decide
whether he the prime minister has broken
the ministerial code i mean that's
another piece of madness which we can
return to another time but
i want to take you on to if you like the
the larger issue here which we know
about um
because there's a lot that we already
know and forgive me if i'm gonna take a
bit of time to lay this out
we know that 16th of april 2021 night
before prince philip's funeral two boozy
parties 18th december 2020 cheese and
wine night days after london went into
tier three
16th december 20th 2020 15 december 2020
14th december 2020 conservative party
headquarters party in the basement i
think 10th of december party at
department for education they've owned
up to that parties 27th of november
2020. 25th november 2020 13th november
2020
20th of may 2020 prime minister spoke
about it this week make the most of the
lovely weather
prime minister finally admitted to
joining that party himself the 15th of
may 2020. these are the things we
already know about we don't have to have
a civil servant to tell us about them
by the way there's every friday friday
wine time now it's taken me ages
to set that out you're the party
chairman
there were a lot of parties
all the while people
in their thousands were sticking to the
rules
and your people
were breaking them
one word shameful right just shameful
yes it was completely unacceptable that
this happened i i feel like an
acceptance of political work i feel i
feel i feel i'm happy to use
whichever adjectives you choose to
express
my anger at what happened i'm angry
about what happened the prime minister
is angry about what happened it should
not have happened there needs to be a
change in the culture but what i would
say to you is that it is important and
it's right to ensure that we find the
full facts of what happened of course
we've seen some of it and we can go
through the detail of each one of them
but we need to get that full picture
which will then enable the prime
minister to respond effectively he will
make a statement to parliament he'll be
held accountable in parliament for his
actions i think that that is the proper
and right process and i don't for a
minute
step back or resile
from the the sense of anger that people
feel about this the question is what do
we do now we need to find out the facts
and then the prime minister needs to
respond effectively and to address the
culture in downing street and i know
that he is committed to doing that
look i i know this is your job to come
on and defend him but you know
it feels like the prime minister himself
is part of the culture and
if i may say everybody thinks you're a
decent
bloke you're an honorable person
on that 20th of may
you were at the podium in downing street
giving the downing street briefing
telling us in good faith that we were
not permitted to meet more than one
other person outside our household
one hour later prime ministers out there
in the party i mean
he has made an absolute mug of you
personally i mean don't you feel
how can you defend this well i'm not
seeking to defend it and noor is the
prime minister and if you look at what
he said to the house of commons on
wednesday he gave a sincere apology for
what happened he gave an explanation
for what had happened it should not have
happened and that was a failure and he
has in credit to the prime minister
owned up to that the question for us now
is how we go broader than just this and
look at the wider cultural issues but
there's also a wider question about
given where we are with omicron as we
emerge
what do we need to do and i think
alongside addressing this we need to
address the consequences of covid
whether that's rebuilding the economy
whether that's cost of living but that
is clearing the nhs backlog and we also
need to get that focus on that and i
know the prime minister is committed to
doing so
look let me uh
you know in the old days people would
have resigned by now wouldn't they i
mean but let's just deal
if i with a specific example because i
think
you've given me the answers that i guess
you have to give but i wonder if
the government really understands what
this anger is about let's take the
weekend of april 16th 17th and 18th last
year
let me remind you what took place
on that saturday there was her majesty
queen
isolated at the funeral of her husband
of 70 years she's unable to sit with her
own family
uh if you don't and
let's not split hairs about the
regulations about the sugray and all
that kind of stuff
but most of the country was thinking
about this that weekend
and i just wonder what kind of people
have not just one but two boozy farewell
parties on the friday night
before this happens
i mean
when you have to go into dining street
meet these people morally how do you
how do you feel about that
well first of all we
all
shared and respected the tremendous
dignity and selflessness that the queen
showed on on this occasion as she has
done throughout her reign and i was
disgusted at the fact that there were
parties taking place before this
profound event of national mourning in
our nation's history it shouldn't have
happened
and it was wrong
that they have already apologized for
doing so
it was just plain wrong and it shouldn't
have happened but but the point i'm
making to you trevor is that we ne i
think in order to move on from this we
first of all need to establish the full
facts of what happened at all the
different
uh alleged events that that took place
and that's the purpose of the sugray
inquiry the next step is then the prime
minister to come to the house of commons
to give a full response to be held into
account for that but i can tell you that
the prime minister is genuinely
committed
both in demonstrating his remorse and
apology for what happened but also in
taking steps to ensure that we address
the kind of culture in downing street
that enabled something like that to
happen which clearly should never have
happened in the first place
but i suppose what i'm really trying to
get at mr dowden is that i understand
the process and all of that
but
i i just wonder whether
prime minister or you really understand
that that process however clean it is
not going to answer
the question that is being asked out
there in the country uh if you'll
forgive me i i've
talked about this once before on this
program and i i hope never hoped never
to have to do it again but
uh
i think there are thousands millions of
people across the country who will feel
frankly rather as i do let's go back to
that april
17th 18th weekend and i just want to say
something about
what i did that during the week and i
think other people have exactly the same
story that week
i saw
my two daughters at various times
outside
one was pregnant one was very ill their
mother stepmother and i weren't allowed
to meet them together
we all stuck to the spirit and the
letter the rules
on the saturday after watching the
funeral of prince philip i went to one
of my friends
70th birthday parties
he'd hired a tent
he's got loads of friends but he's had a
tent for just six of us so we can sit
outside he's stuck to the spirit and the
letter of the rules
at that dinner i get a call my
daughter's collapsed and as you will
know
for months she's
you know she'd been isolated she was ill
by the following morning
she had died and she had stuck to the
spirit
and let her the rules now they're going
to be thousands of people who have that
story
in their
background
and if i may say so
you are in here telling me about a civil
servant's inquiry that will not answer
that
anger
what is does the prime minister really
understand
why people are angry
well first of all i know how much you
have suffered during this period and i
know how much so many people in this
country have suffered the probations
that they have been subject to
the steadfastness with which people
obeyed the rules and it is totally wrong
if there has been any way in which and
we've seen some examples of this those
rules have not been
fully obeyed in downing street what i'm
trying to
offer to you and to your viewers who may
be watching this program
is to explain to you how the government
is seeking to move forward through this
first of all to establish all of the
facts of what happened and then the
prime minister
will be held to account in parliament
for what happened and i want to assure
you and i want to assure any of your
viewers listening i've discussed with
the prime minister on many occasions he
has a sincere sense of remorse
and regret at what happened
as do i as to other members of the
government all right look let me go sir
forgive me let me get back to actually
doing my job here but the truth of the
matter is still is the politics of this
are that you're facing a consistent poll
deficit biggest in 8 years
and in reality you know what the most
decisive thing you as party chair could
do about this so let me just ask you
again
when you're going to tell the prime
minister that he himself is the
principal object that stands in the way
of your doing your job successfully
which is to get the conservative party
re-elected to government
well i do not believe that the prime
minister should resign for the the
reasons that we have discussed in this
interview i do though think it is
essential that we address the kind of
failings that allow this to happen that
the prime minister is held to account
for what happened and addresses that in
parliament and that we also
build on the kind of work that we have
done with the vaccine rollout program to
address the subsequent challenges of
covert whether that's clearing the nhs
backlog or rebuilding the economy i
think that that is the right approach
rather than going through a period of
divisive
leadership contest which
is not the sense that i get of what
british people want us to be focusing on
they want us to focus on the job at hand
of dealing with omicron and then the
consequences of covert
old thank you very much
well with westminster royaling
widespread anger up and down the country
it's also a critical moment for the
labour party
having bided its time in recent months
the leadership has now called for boris
johnson to resign and the party's taken
a commanding lead in the polls
consistently 10 or more points ahead of
the conservatives so with the election
potentially less than two years away is
labour ready for government i'm joined
now by the shadow health secretary
where's streeting now we're streeting if
your leader gets his way you'd be health
secretary sooner rather than later so um
could we just dispense with the bit
where i say
you know
i ask you about something and then you
tell me what's wrong with the
government's actions and go straight to
the part where i asked you this given
all
the signs are that on the omicron wave
though not gone is less dangerous than
it was would you be inclined if you were
health secretary to relax the current
restrictions at the next review on
january 26th well we'll follow the data
closely we hope so in that we don't want
any more restrictions or measures than
are absolutely necessary i think the
cautionary note we've got to bear in
mind is that london might be over the
peak of the wave the rest of england is
still bearing the brunt of it and for
lots of reasons particularly population
size capacity and resilience london's
nhs system is in a stronger position
than other parts of the nhs so we can't
be complacent about that what i have
done today
though is send a very strong message to
the country about the need to live well
with covert and we've heard
lots of conservative mps talk about
living with covid and my anxiety about
that has been two fronts there are some
conservative backbenchers who for whom
living with covid means
ending all measures including the
testing regime and everything else
that's reckless and irresponsible you've
got the health sector who says we need
to live with kovid but doesn't seem to
have a plan so we set out 10 points that
we think the government should introduce
in order to live well with covert in
longer term some are things they should
do immediately some are longer-term
objectives but the goal here is to make
sure that we never have to go into
lockdown again and that we can move
forward as a country protecting public
health but doing so in a way that
protects lives livelihoods and liberties
so in fact you are already preparing for
as it were to shift from a pandemic to
endemic yes and i think that's the
sensible thing to do and and you're
right say at the outset we can't be
complacent we're following the data i
was reassured actually by what oliver
dowden said about following the data
because i'll be honest my anxiety
reading the sunday papers this morning
was that this stuff about ending plan b
measures was driven more by the politics
of the situation uh you know boris
johnson's personal political problems
needing to throw some red meat to back
benches who might be writing the letters
in and trying to say oh let's move on
from the downing street parties onto
onto plan b measures and grab some
headlines so um i i want the government
to be motivated by public health and as
you remember from when i came on before
christmas one of the reasons why we
signaled labour support for plan b
measures well in advance of the vote was
to give the health secretary the
confidence to know he had the votes so
my message to him this morning
we've got regardless of all the noise
about boris johnson
and the mess he's caused for his own
party and government let's keep public
health at the forefront of our minds and
let's plan on that basis well it's
rather um difficult to avoid the mess uh
that
as you described it that uh miss
johnson's cause if you want to put it
that way
and just in passing i apologize to
viewers if i brought something personal
into into this discussion let's try and
uh keep above that um now your parties
obviously benefited from the revelations
uh that have been coming out day off
today
but let's just clear up one thing
because it came up yesterday
um your only does not averse to a quick
snifter during the working daisy
there's no comparison between
kierstarma following the rules in 2021
and boris johnson breaking the rules in
2020 no comparison whatsoever and i
understand why uh the conservative party
unable to defend boris johnson wants to
now start going on the attack and
smearing other people to cause
distraction but there is there is
genuinely no comparison between the two
uh the two
and i i think
what we've got to do
is to
show could you go back to the point
about the politics
that it's not enough for labor for the
government to lose the next election
we've got to earn trust and win the next
general election and by the way trevor i
don't think you should apologize for
talking about your personal pain because
millions of people up and down the
country are having the same conversation
it's come up on the doorstep time and
time again in recent days and i think
that that image we saw of the queen
isolating the reason why that image is
so powerful is two fronts
one it showed that people were following
the rules and if her majesty the queen
who is actually genuinely the only
person in the country who is legally
above the law thought it was important
to follow the rules and set an example
why did the prime minister think that
somehow he was above the rules
and and and what the queen has done as
she often does is epitomize a national
mood and a national moment and
she took that responsibility seriously
in the way the prime minister didn't so
i think people are furious and hurt and
actually one of the uh most powerful
interviews i heard this week was a
caller into a radio program
who
was in bits because he'd enforce the
rules at funerals and was now asking if
he'd done the right thing and felt
terribly guilty about it
and that's what the prime minister
either doesn't understand or doesn't
care about was that people were doing
the right thing we were all in it
together boris johnson and number 10
weren't and that's why he's unfit for
office
against that background and you know i i
we don't have to argue about what you
just said um
it's curious that you know labour is
asked is has said rhetorically prime
minister must resign
but why is there
no vote of confidence why are you
leaving this to tory back benches just
to sort out
well i think there are three routes to
the prime minister going um he could do
the right thing and resign but boris
johnson and doing the right thing rarely
appear in the same sentence he can be
removed by conservative mps
through a motion of no confidence
through the 1922 committee and i
understand more letters are coming in
but they're not there yet or he can be
removed by the electorate those are the
three routes to the prime minister going
and i think what conservative mps need
to weigh up very carefully is whether in
the end they are going to allow a toxic
radioactive prime minister to
contaminate their party because one of
the reasons i push back on the idea that
they're all the same is that when things
like this happen in politics sometimes
the voters do say you're all the same i
don't think we're all the same i don't
think most conservative mps were out
breaking the rules but voters will judge
them if they defend the indefensible if
they stand by the prime minister if
they're complicit by their silence and
that's why they should remove him
because otherwise the voters will remove
them at the next general election hang
on i don't really understand this i mean
one of the routes is a vote of no
confidence in parliament which you could
instigate we cannot you do we could
bring forward a motion of no confidence
in the government we've been around the
blocks with this before that would
galvanize the conservative party that
would be the politicians
how do you know that that would be the
politician you don't know that until you
try it i i i i just don't think that's
true i mean i know tory mps well enough
trevor to know the way they behave they
don't want to bring down the
conservative government i imagine they
are concluding uh in their own
minds and judgment and in their own
consciences that boris johnson is unfit
for office the question now is whether
they have the courage to act
well look um
i don't want to seem overly cynical here
mr streeting but actually uh there is a
point of view that says
that the people who most benefit from
having boris johnson
deeply wounded damaged but still in
office is uh the labour party and that
actually for you having him clinging on
in number 10 uh is better for you as a
party even if getting him out
you think would be better for the
country
all of this rhetoric is really just a
way of making sure he stays there don't
also make no bones about it boris
johnson carrying on is great for the
labour party if i'm thinking about this
purely through the prison of party
politics my message to tory mps is keep
him on knock yourselves out literally
you'll be knocked out of the next
election but we're still in the middle
of a national crisis here and the prime
minister's actions and judgments matter
in fact it comes back to the point i
made about plan b measures
if a prime minister or health secretary
from the conservative party is coming
forward and saying we're going to remove
plan b measures i want to be absolutely
confident they're making that decision
in the national interest and not in the
party interest for party management
reasons i don't have total confidence
about that it's one of the reasons why
in the coming days i'll be talking to
leaders of the nhs and talking to
government scientists and other
scientists to get their independent
impartial view because i can't trust the
moment ministers are guided by one
principle and one principle alone which
is public health before party politics
so this is not good for the country i
think boris johnson ought to go in the
national interest i know we'll be stuck
with the conservative government for a
bit longer and i hope it is just a bit
longer
and the responsibility ultimately falls
on us to show the voters that we're not
complacent we're not waiting for
government to fall into our laps we
don't think it's the case that because
the tories are in a mess that people
just flock to labour by default we want
to win people's trust i mean that's why
yesterday kierstama did a big speech
about the future of health and social
care he could have just banged on about
boris johnson for 20 minutes and
everyone would have loved it but he did
that speech to show the country that
labour has a plan labor has a vision for
the country labour is ready for
government indeed well he's he's made
speeches like that before and it doesn't
seem to be working because um this
morning's opinion poll which puts you
ten
points ahead as a party has a rather
interesting finding and let me just
quote what the director of research is
opinion says when we tested possible
successes to johnson while most of the
cabinet got negative ratings nearly half
of people say they think rishi sunak
would be a good prime minister a figure
that is higher than both labour's vote
share and kirsten's approval rating so
actually
your uh vote lead is really more to do
with johnson's unpopularity than the uh
the the the idea that the voters have
had a come to jesus moment labor and
discovered that labour is is the what
they're looking for well we're
absolutely not completely complacent
care is not complacent whenever we get
new polls out showing a labor lead here
is the first person to say we're not
looking at this through roast tinted
glasses we've got work to do still to
win back trust but that's why in the new
year he did a big speech outlining his
vision for the country and the
principles that would underpin a labor
government followed up very quickly by
substantial speech about health and
social care you'll be hearing more about
this from care and from the rest of the
shadow cabinet over this year because
this is the year where we will be saying
to the country we've got a terrible
government the country deserves a better
alternative here is labour's alternative
and that's where we'll be in 2022. all
right one quick last question um labour
backbencher barry gardner received over
400 000 pounds from a source linked to
the chinese communist party for his
political work
will he and any other mp who benefited
from that kind of money be required to
return it by the labour party
i don't know that we can require him to
to return it i do think this is very
serious
i do think that we've got a real issue
here
which extends beyond one labour mp it's
also about access to government
ministers that's why to be honest both
of our parties aren't treating this as a
party political knockabout it's being
taken very seriously by the leadership
of both parties we can't have a
situation where a foreign government
particularly one hostile to
britain's interest on a number of levels
is able to directly interfere in our
politics that's what we've got to draw a
line under and i hope that very quickly
we'll be having a full review of what's
happened the lessons that need to be
learned we also need to act very quickly
uh the intelligence security committee
made a whole number of recommendations
in relation to the russia report many of
those haven't yet been implemented so i
think there's an urgency to act national
security's got to come first we're
streaming thank you very much for your
time this morning thank you
the phrase famous civil servant should
actually be a contradiction in terms the
white hall machine is supposed to wear
away silently in the political
background
but this week you couldn't really escape
hearing or reading the name sue gray
she's holding an investigation into the
parties held in downing street and
elsewhere in whitehall during the
pandemic
conservative mps and number 10 plead
with us to wait for the conclusions of
her report as if she can determine the
future of boris johnson but actually she
can't that is in his own hands and those
of his party
but there are wider questions about
civil servants and the culture in
whitehall
the fda is the union representing senior
civil servant in whitehall and beyond
and its general secretary dave penman
joins me now good morning mr penman good
morning
um now i i don't mean to call it any
offense here but most people couldn't
name a civil servant if they tried but
obviously you'd have to be living under
rock not to have heard sue gray's name
um do you think she's being set up to
fail by conservative mps and number 10
because um
actually
her investigation can't possibly answer
some of the questions that i raised with
uh
oliver dalton can it
no it can't i mean ultimately sue um
has been tasked with finding facts and
that's what the civil service is good at
the civil service um and its day job
advises ministers collects evidence and
as its duty under the civil service code
says it should it should give
evidence-based advice and so even in
these uh tricky political issues what
sue will do is amass the evidence and
present that evidence to the prime
minister ultimately this is an internal
investigation and the prime minister
will have choices around what he does
with that report the degree to which he
publishes it what information he puts in
the public domain the decisions that
will be taken for civil servants because
civil servants may face disciplinary
action around this but we then find
ourselves with this kind of perverse
position where if actually it
demonstrates as a question about whether
the prime minister breached the
ministerial code only the prime minister
himself can refer himself for an
investigation so it's not going to
deliver what and some people are put on
it but what it should do is deliver the
facts
but do you think
well what do you think then happens i
mean she just says this is what takes
place i mean
is the prime minister then going to be
judge and jury
on himself i mean how does this work
well unfortunately that's the case
i mean ultimately as i said you know
there's a lot of public scrutiny here in
parliamentary scrutiny so i think you
know if you look if you look at kind of
previous investigations uh the
investigation that was done into the
home secretary the prime minister sat on
for six months because he didn't like
the result and it was perfectly
inconvenient to him and when it was
first over we just ignored it and so so
ultimately the prime minister is going
to have to think about what the
consequences of dealing with any
inconvenient facts that come from this
report and the degree to which he
publishes all of it or a summary of it
but really the problem with our current
system is when it comes to the prime
minister himself he essentially has a
veto of whether he's investigated uh and
i don't think that's good enough you
look at the governments elsewhere uh in
the country in scotland they're just
introducing a new system with
independent investigations and
independent education we really need a
better system for dealing with not only
the prime minister but ministers when it
comes to oversight of their conduct
i mean i i'm not sure whether you
actually represent
sue gray whether she's a member of the
fda or not but would you actually have
said when this
started that actually she probably
shouldn't do that do this job and that
it should have gone as you say to
somebody completely independent of
government
even uh independent of the uh
the the adviser on ministers interests
lord guide
but well ultimately when this
investigation was originally launched it
wasn't just about the prime minister it
was a broader issue about number 10 and
the revelations that were in the public
domain at that time and more revelations
have come out and since then but
ultimately this is the job of a civil
servant a civil servant doesn't get to
choose and sue grey is a formidable
character and she has been used to
dealing with the most sensitive
political issues she was head of the
proprietary and ethics team at cabin
office she's investigated ministers
before and given prime ministers very
difficult messages about those
investigations so so there isn't anyone
really in whitehall better to do it than
sugary herself but that's not really
good enough for the for the public the
public need to understand that this is
what the civil service does the civil
service is it's not independent but it's
permanent and it's impartial and it has
demonstrated time and time again that it
can present a prime minister reluctant
to receive those facts with the
unvarnished truth the difficulty here is
what happens then so so ultimately the
civil servants will do what they've been
asked to do and they'll do it to the
best of their ability they'll do it
under the civil service code where
they'll be dealing with facts and
evidence and tell the truth and then
we're left with how the prime minister
will determine on those facts
it's very difficult to tell exactly
what's going to happen here but of
course uh there's endless gossip in
whitehall and some of it is in
newspapers today we um
we read that the number 10 strategy
appears to be to save boris johnson at
all costs uh
apparently it's called operation save
big dog um
that probably means that if that's what
they want to do
some smaller dogs are going to get
thrown to the walls if i can
mangle the metaphor um
do you think that's fair and and what
can you do about it because those
smaller dogs are going to be your people
aren't they
yeah well i mean ultimately everyone has
to be accountable for their conduct from
the most junior civil servant to the
prime minister when we were all under
those restrictions everyone had personal
choices to make all the time whether it
was at home or whether it was at work
and i don't think there's any hiding
from that but ultimately you have to ask
yourself some questions about how a
culture was created uh in number 10
where this was deemed acceptable and
those in leadership positions bear the
most responsibility for this i mean
there's talk in the papers of a civil
service culture that's not a civil
service culture i recognize after being
around whitehall for 20 years it might
be a number 10 culture but it's not a
civil service culture and and certainly
from from reading what others have said
it doesn't even seem like a number 10
culture from previous prime minister so
i think ultimately when you're looking
at responsibility those who lead a
culture and an organization quite a
small organization in number 10 there's
only about 400 staff who create an
environment with these sorts of
decisions can be taken never mind
potentially participating um in them
then i think that's where there's a
greater responsibility and sue gray will
know that soodley has worked in and
around government for decades she knows
um how these sort of manifestations
happen in cultures within management and
i'm sure she'll be alive to that fact as
well when she's considered on her
recommendation okay
let let me just uh pick you up on this
point about the culture because it's not
just number 10 we saw it in department
for education we don't yet know where
else this kind of thing has happened
can you put your hand on your heart and
say that there isn't a culture of
you know six o'clock we've had a hard
day let's get in a bottle of a cheeky
merlot
across westminster i mean this thing
seems to be quite normalized and not
entirely contained to west to number 10.
well well i would challenge that trevor
because what we've got is one incident
in another government department um
where there was a leave in doing a
mistake made and they held up their
hands quite quickly on that i mean if
you can imagine i get calls several
times a day from journalists trying to
find that on what was happening
elsewhere and none of that's come out of
course i can't say what's happened in
every government department but my
experience of 20 years around whitehall
would say this is not an environment and
a culture that has got that sort of
approach to it certainly not and when
you talk about it in the middle of
lockdown you know this number 10 was not
the only bit of the civil service where
people were in at their desk working 24
hours a day during um
the pandemic you know about a quarter of
the civil service has always been in the
palms of dwp it's been it's been 50
percent throughout so ultimately you
know everyone has faced choices across
government and there are most real
stories coming out about elsewhere so i
think as far as i can
uh sure this is not a civil service
culture this really is about number 10.
all right
dave penman thank you very much indeed
very much
well as if there isn't enough going on
in westminster this week it all got a
bit double07 when mi5 issued a rare
warning about a chinese agent who had
infiltrated parliament and was
influencing current and aspiring mps
it meant some awkward questions for
labour's barry gardner and others and
left many mps already concerned about
china's activities calling for a harder
line
leading those calls this week was ian
duncan smith and he was of course leader
of the conservative party in the early
2000s at a time when the party also
trailed labor in the polls so he knows
plenty about the challenges to the
leadership he joins me now live from his
constituency good morning mr duncan
smith um
if we could start with the
parliamentary issue
um mi5 had to issue an urgent alert
because of the activities of the chinese
agent affecting our parliament and that
established
a link between the communist party in
china and current and aspiring members
of parliament now another week we'd be
talking about
nothing else pretty much
but
um even in this week it's still pretty
shocking isn't it
it is and um the reality for us is that
i think successive governments have been
completely asleep at the wheel over this
issue
um
completely asleep at the wheel
and
the reality therefore is that we need to
figure out where we are with china
whether we have a relationship or
whether they are seen as a threat
if you look back at the foreign defense
report
you will see that they categorize russia
as a threat but china is a competitor
and it does then lead you to wonder why
that was the case and the answer is i
think that
china over the years has so dominated us
in a way that we are now completely
dependent on them for a whole series of
items and articles
they've got themselves into the position
of being able to invest into our nuclear
industry most of the
solar arrays the elements on them are
produced by slave labor from xinjiang
the insides of most of the
wind turbines that we have are all made
in china we've become utterly dependent
and far too many officials and
ex-ministers
have then left and retired and gone and
taken uh money from china so uh the very
fact that they are in trying to persuade
and infiltrate
and subvert people within our political
system is nothing new at all but the
worst bit about it is the government too
many governments seem too
cautious about calling it out this is a
brutal dictatorial ghastly regime and we
seem to want to
i think cow tower to them too often and
that's dangerous and you've seen the
results of that and this is just the tip
of the iceberg i can promise you
i wonder if you could be clear about why
this is such a big problem because
politicians take donations from all
sorts of people don't they and
part of that undoubtedly must be because
those people want to influence those
politicians and
you know we elect we hope
independent-minded people who won't be
swayed why is this particular issue such
a big deal
well number one we're dealing with a
regime which is committing genocide we
are dealing with a regime that has
trashed a british sino-british
international treaty on hong kong we're
dealing with a regime that is locking up
peaceful democracy campaigners
and threatening taiwan we also deal with
the regime that has killed indian
soldiers on its border in disputes and
has taken over the south china seas and
has threatened everybody and anybody and
is now subverting countries in africa uh
you see the other day that if they don't
pay their loans back which they're given
i saw the other day i think it was in
sri lanka they've taken over a port
pretty much
i mean this goes on we are not dealing
with a
a european regime or an american regime
which is democratic and accountable this
is a brutal disgusting regime and what
they're after is making sure there can
be no criticism of them so they can
break every rule that they wish and they
do
and therefore we won't and after all
let's just be reminded of one thing you
know covid19 kovid19 whether or not we
believe it came from a laboratory or not
you know the communist regime of china
refused to let the world know of the
scale of the problem they had until very
late on uh well over a month month and a
half
before they told officially the who by
the way the who
themselves seemed conflicted because
they should have been asking direct
questions but they didn't the result is
that has spread around the world so when
you're dealing with a regime like this
that doesn't tell the truth that doesn't
open up and is brutal then this sort of
thing you know millions have died as a
result of that so we can't just treat
the chinese government as any other
government you know so when they start
infiltrating when they start subverting
parliament and when they start paying
people off we've got to be much much
much more brutal about it and australia
shows us the way to do this which is to
ban uh in involvement with the uh the
chinese authorities and china
in critical circumstances
well just very quickly though
we've identified one individual uh
christine uh cinque li um
do you believe that there are other
people
doing this
oh absolutely certainly uh i think this
is the tip of the iceberg let's just
look at universities for example
in plain sight you've got the confucius
institute which
offers to pay
to
help students understand china in fact
what so much of it does is spy on
chinese students many of our
universities have become completely
dependent on chinese students i was
talking to one the other day that had
allowed members of the embassy to come
to one of their debates about china so
they could literally spy on who was
saying what i mean this goes on
everywhere you know if you look at where
their money goes whether it's huawei or
anything else you know it's all about
subverting us and making sure that they
can undercut
the bid contracts etc and win contracts
and win over the uk so it's very
important okay we recognize china as a
threat not as a competitor
right forgive me for interrupting you
but i i want to move on to of course the
issue of the day let me be absolutely
straight forward in asking this question
um let's leave the
technicalities and even the kind of
small politics out of this um you've
done the job
do you think that boris johnson is
morally
fitted
to remain as leader of the conservative
party
well one rule i always made for myself
is not to enter the world of morals i'll
leave that
to those who practice and preach and
deliver religion and once politicians
start yeah it's about morals
forgive me you will have been talking to
your constituents this weekend
completely different
it would be hard to imagine that that
question is not being asked
between them and
to you
well you know
is it a morality question or is it a
question about whether or not
these things should have happened so
let's let's remove the two and just deal
with the reality
this is unforgivable there is no
question that what has been going on uh
and despite your previous interviewee
has unearthed the culture which has
become lazy and slack about what happens
after hours what happens in offices
you know most businesses wouldn't allow
what was going on in the offices even
though people have been under pressure
this was in the middle of lockdown with
oppressive rules
about what people could and couldn't do
and there's no question
my constituents other constitutions are
quite rightly very angry about the fact
that many of them were having to obey
what some of us felt were over onerous
rules but nonetheless they were rules
and yet there seemed to be others doing
things that they weren't able to do at
the heart of government maybe across
government too in other departments so
the key thing here is this was wrong
there is no question for it there's no
there's no explanations there's just
apology and contrition and we have to
see now what sue grey comes up with the
extent of it
who was responsible and how this all
worked
all right let let me take the word moral
or morality out of my question and put
this to you again
because you've been there
isn't this a matter of character
and isn't the danger here
that the character of your leader
is essentially
defining the conservative party and
potentially losing people like you with
your
not gigantic majority your seat
well as i said earlier on this is not an
issue about quibbling as to why or
wherefore this is about
understanding that responsibility always
in these issues comes to the heart
of it all and it's about the prime
minister's authority and about his
decision-making and whether or not he
knew or understood what was going on uh
is a question that sue gray will settle
but there's no question right now
that this is an appalling set of
circumstances it should not have
happened none of them should have
happened you know what i can't
understand is why there wasn't a sign
nailed up on every door of every
government department including downing
street that would have said simply when
you have finished your work go home
go home not stop by
that sort of level of understanding is
beyond me and i'm not figured out so
absolutely not i mean i'm as appalled as
anybody else i'm as appalled as my
constituents uh it's simply uh appalling
one way or the other part we have to see
finally we call for this inquiry let us
see what it comes up with and then we
will make ourselves excuse me
thank you very much ian duncan smith um
thank you for your time this morning
now we've understandably talked a lot
today about the future of the prime
minister and party politics in
westminster
but believe it or not there are other
very very significant things happening
abroad right now
the pentagon says russia is planning to
fabricate attacks as a pretext to invade
ukraine
again
russia's dismissed the claims of course
but has a hundred thousand troops on the
ukrainian border and talked between
moscow and nato ended in failure this
week
earlier i spoke to kurt volcker formerly
the u.s ambassador to nato and the
special representative to ukraine he's
worked under president bush obama and
trump
i started by asking him how dangerous he
thinks the situation is
i think it is very real um very
dangerous probably the most dangerous it
has been since the last time russia
invaded which is 2014.
you remember then that
russia in stealthily went into crimea
used little green men and special forces
took over crimea did the same thing
again in eastern ukraine and there's now
been a war going on at a very low level
for seven years about 14 000 people have
been killed on the ukrainian side but it
appears as though putin has put in place
all of the forces necessary to launch a
fresh new large invasion
and he is making all kinds of threats to
the west and to nato that if he doesn't
get some kind of guarantee about
ukraine being under russia's fear of
influence he's going to do it again
it um it's thought unlikely that he
would simply march across the border the
pentagon
says that russia is planning a so-called
false flag attack to fabricate fabricate
a reason to invade um
do you think that's how this kind of
thing starts
um it can
it's not the only way but i think it can
i think what putin was attempting to do
or what the pentagon is saying he was
attempting to do was have russian
special forces
acting as though they were ukrainians
attacking the russian-led forces in
eastern ukraine in order to give them a
reason to come back and attack those
forces and go massively into ukraine
that's one way to get this started there
might be other ways as well if you
remember in 2014
russia used
regular military and special forces in
unmarked uniforms to take over
government buildings and declare an
insurrection and then when ukraine tried
to put down the insurrection massively
slowed in so-called humanitarian
assistance which turned out to be a lot
of weaponry and a lot of troops
but i think the sort of thing softening
up the target creating the pretext it's
also why he wanted to have these
meetings with the us and nato to get a
rejection of his ideas he's trying to
create the pretext for justifying
going into ukraine again
so that's how you read the talks in
vienna this week which seem
frankly forgot nowhere
yes and i think entirely predictable
putin knew that the demands that he put
into the texts that he gave to the us
and nato in december would be absolutely
unacceptable
nato is not going to say no countries
can ever join again
nato is not going to say that we will
withdraw our military protection of the
baltic states and poland
nato is not going to say that russia has
a right to determine the future and
security aspirations of its neighbors
knowing that why would he then propose
these things
i think on the one hand of course if we
were to give him that he'd be happy
but more realistically he knew he would
get a rejection and he wanted to show
that he made the effort at dialogue and
diplomacy but he was rejected so he
quote unquote had no choice
there's been a lot of activity this week
um
ukraine was hit by a massive cyber
attack warning its citizens to be
quote afraid and expect the worst now um
we don't know who exactly is behind that
attack but if it does turn out to be
a russian or russian inspired
because you've seen something similar in
the past
what action could be taken
well first off let's analyze that attack
a little bit it um
there have been cyber attacks against
ukraine against estonia uh in the united
states against our election system in
germany even in the uk i believe so
it would be fitting the pattern for this
to be russia and surprising if it's not
second what is the message here it is
psychological pressure on ukraine we can
attack your government ministries
anytime we want to we can put up our
messages on those ministries and we only
did the civilian ones this time we
didn't do your military the implicit
threat being we can do your military so
i think this is a lot of psychological
pressure on ukraine as far as what can
be done about cyber attacks it's it's
probably too late to prevent things now
it is something that all of us need to
do in in the west in ukraine in our
partner countries help them build
resilience against cyber attacks
but it's something that needs to be
done constantly and with vigilance not
something that at the spur of the moment
we can change mr putin has amassed a
hundred thousand russian troops on the
border he says i can do what i like on
my own soil
but
it's evident that this is at some level
um a kind of intimidation what do you
think is larger game is here what is
what is the point of all of this
well i think
it is what he said it is
which is uh he wants to prevent ukraine
from ever being admitted to nato he
wants nato to basically agree to tear up
the helsinki accords and this idea that
every state has a right to its
sovereignty and territorial integrity
every state can choose its own alliances
this foundation of security in europe
that's been in place for 50 years he
wants to tear that up and replace it
with something more like yalta which is
there's an eastern sphere of influence
and that's ours and there's a western
sphere of influence you can play there
and this is a deal between stalin and uh
western leaders correct yes he's looking
to go back to that as opposed to the
arrangements for european security that
have been in place for decades and i
would connect this to a vision that he
has
remember he was a kgb officer in eastern
germany
he was deeply disappointed with the fall
of the soviet union called it the
greatest tragedy of the 20th century and
believed that it was the fault of the
leaders of the soviet union at that time
to allow that to happen
i think he sees himself in the mode of a
builder of the greater russia and he
seeks to acquire territories as he's
done already with crimea or occupies
parts of ukraine or georgia or the soft
takeover he's done in belarus and
possibly even now in kazakhstan so i
think he sees himself as reassembling
the pieces of a greater russia and this
happens of course in the anniversary
year of the founding of the soviet union
i think he'd like to emerge from this
year having shown that he has built
something big
let's get to the sharp end of this you
spend a lot of time
in talks with russians who've been uh
involved uh in the politics of the
ukraine for
many years do you think
in reality that
it is a real possibility that he could
invade
yes yes i would say that in my way of
looking at it is more likely than not
his rhetoric has escalated to a point
that will make it very hard not to
follow through
uh it is clear that the west cannot give
him the the guarantees and demands that
he is seeking
and i think that he actually will want
to make some kind of invasion some kind
of territorial acquisition but he'll
want to do it swiftly he'll want to stop
within a short period of time and then
try to connect these territories of
crimea and donbass and maybe other parts
of ukraine and make them part of what is
a sphere of influence for russia by
action since he's not going to get that
by words from nato or the u.s well you
say he won't get it by word so what can
nato and the us do for example there i
guess there's some people who think that
maybe to exceed to the demand
that ukraine would never join nato
would be one way of at least getting him
back to the negotiating table
well what it would do is it would give
him something and cause him to think
well what else should i be getting as
well he's not going to stop with getting
his demands met we've seen this this
movie many times
and moreover it is not for us to sign
away the rights of 40 million ukrainians
it is for them to decide the future of
their own country now what the us and
europe are doing
is threatening massive retaliatory
sanctions if russia does invade again
in increasing these military presence in
nato allies in eastern europe and
increasing security assistance to
ukraine so they can better defend
themselves but all of this is being
framed as a response if russia attacks
again
and i think that what we really should
be doing is taking the all three of
those steps but doing it right away as a
deterrent to such an invasion with a
promise that we could wind down some of
that if russia stands its forces down
and we're no longer negotiating under
the threat of the use of force
so you would stand
next to former secretary of state uh
mike pompeo when he criticizes the biden
administration for basically talking and
not doing um because uh
pompeo has said that putin is prepared
to
push to the brink is it his expression
in ukraine to get what he wants you are
in favor
of more aggressive tactics
well i wouldn't describe what i said as
aggressive uh i do believe that we need
to be doing rather than talking only uh
and i think that that he's right about
that but helping a country get the
armaments and training so it can defend
itself is not an aggressive step uh it
is a prudent one to help stave off such
an invasion putting sanctions against a
country that is now using extortionist
type threats against nato against
ukraine against europe
that's not an unreasonable thing to do
either and we'd be willing to lift those
sanctions if russia stopped its
intimidating activity
i don't see these as aggressive moves i
see them as prudent defensive moves to
put in place to try to stave off
something worse
i was interested in the uh pompeo
intervention is this a sign uh that mr
pompeo is now gearing up for a run in
2024 is this the opening of the
political hostilities
for um the elections
in states later on this year and then
the 2024
presidential election
yeah i read an article yesterday where
there was a debate about when did the
2024 presidential election campaign
begin is it 2022 was it in 2020 just
after the january 6th riots or did it
actually begin in 2020 before the 2020
election and people are already jostling
for 2024.
i think it may have been the latter as
well too
no one knows at this stage who is going
to run on the republican side it is
quite possible that former president
trump would run again there are a number
of strong republican candidates mike
pompeo among them who might want to try
as well
a lot of them are doing the kinds of
things you need to do to prepare so they
can make a decision later if they choose
to run
and i think mike pompeo would be one of
the stronger candidates if he did
well that's as much as we've got time
for this morning
obviously news isn't going to stop and
we will be back next sunday with more
exciting and perhaps over emotional
politics
[Music]
in a moment i'm going to talk to sam
coats on the take
[Music]
you